فنان شاب كان اول ظهور له كطفل في فيلم
بحب السيما امام النجمين محمود حميده
وليلى علوي الان يشارك الفنان الشاب يوسف
عثمان في مسلسل الغرفه 207 والذي يعرض على
منصه شاهد حول دوره في هذا المسلسل
والادوار التي يبحث عنها 10 صباح العربيه
لقاء مع يوسف عثمان خلال مشاركه في مهرجان
القاهره السينمائي
[موسيقى]
اربع حب حضرتك على قناه العربيه كلمني على
اخر اعمالك بتعمل ايه دلوقت دلوقت الحمد
لله رب العالمين 207 من اكثر الحاجات اللي
الناس حابه ان هو التشويقي وفي خلال اربع
حلقات النهارده الناس حبه الرعب والخفي
والتشويق في متقدم بطريقه حلوه مع
الالتزام بحاجات كانت في الروايه كاتبها
دكتور احمد خالد توفيق الحمد الله رد
الفعل جاي كويسه على شخصيه مصطفى على
طريقته على كذا حد بيعلق على كمان دي
شخصيه مختلفه قوي عن الحاجات اللي كنت
عملتها قبل كده
كان بيشوفني مبسوط هنا ولا لا
بعد اللي حصل اللي كان شغال قبل كده
هو ايه اللي حصل اللي كان شغال قبل كده
وانت ما تعرفش
وهاعرف منين
ولا انت
معلش يا استاذ جمال
ما تدخلنيش في الكلام ده وبرده بدايه عرض
مسلسل العيله دي ده مسلسل كوميدي
مع محمد ثروت مع اسلام ابراهيم واسماعيل
فرغلي
افلام رعب
اغلب جمهور المنصات شباب ده شايفه ازاي
اللي فتح الباب ده بتدي حريه الصنع مؤلفين
او منتجين او مخرجين ان هم يعملوا انواع
مختلفه عن الدراما اللي احنا متعودين
عليها في رمضان سواء فورمات 30 حلقه او
فورمه 15 حلقه فده اللي بيفتح او بيعمل
حريه اكثر
همم زي العيله دي عشان كده باقول لك دوري
في غرفه 207 بعيد عندها تماما فحابب ان
الناس بتقول لي ده شخصيه مختلفه تماما عن
ان احنا مستنيينه منك وده حاجه بسطتني قوي
من اكثر من الحاجات الجمله دي بسيطه يعني